quatre jours déjà se sont écoulées le
périmètre de sécurité a été retiré pour
la première fois depuis l'attentât au
bataclan il est possible de s'en
approcher
c'est ce qu'a fait olga à la taille avec
son violon et les venues jouer avant de
tout l'effort de jouer pour ceux qui
étaient à l'intérieur
il faut continuer de faire de la musique
dit-elle car la musique est un langage
qui unit les gens devant la salle de
spectacle les fleurs les bougies et les
messages continuent de s'accumuler
à peine de retour en france elodie est
venu s'y recueillir
caporal-chef dans l'armée française elle
revient tout juste d'une mission anti
terroriste au tchad et au niger
si différent qu'on trouve à l'essor
quand c'est son propre pays qui se fait
attaquer on ressent pas de la même façon
on va se battre
ne pas se laisser abattre par ce qu il s
est passé
ne pas se laisser abattre c'est pour
cela qu'elle café des anges a rouvert
ses portes
mais l'ambiance ici n'est pas à la fête
et pour cause
vendredi soir ou d'assad in serveuse ici
fêté son 35e anniversaire elle avait
invité et sa soeur à lima ses collègues
ses amis à célébrer l'événement au bar
la belle équipe
onze d'entre eux sont morts sur cette
terrasse fauchés par des rafales de
kalachnikov
la crise guillaume romain michelli sont
des noms qui résonnent ici cruellement
absents et pourtant tellement présent en
buvant un verre justement justement ça
se passe on buvait un verre ensemble
elle est partie en faisant un clin
d'oeil
je me souviens de sa comme tous ici
morgane marc elle essaie de se
concentrer sur son travail mais
certaines questions reviennent sans
cesse bajeux monde
s'ils ont souffert si ça a été radical
si on les perd si les rues le temps
d'avoir peur
comprendre ce qui leur arrivait musée
monde forcément ça ce que j'essaie de
m'imaginer la scène savoir comment ça
s'est passé sur la terrasse tous les
clients sont au courant ils sont venus
pour s'amuser mais aussi par solidarité
c'est une manière de
de se révolter justement contre les
attentats qui ont eu lieu vendredi
c'est aussi pour faire un pied-de-nez à
des shows clermont sait on est là parce
qu'on a des convictions et qu'on est
français on n'a pas peur en réaction aux
attentats
un mot clic est devenue virale sur
internet tous au bistrot un mot d'ordre
s'asseoir à la terrasse d'un café pour
résister pour ne pas se laisser
intimider
et si jean françois bélanger radio
canada